PETE LEPAGE: Hey, everybody, and
welcome to another edition
of the Chrome Apps
Office Hours.
Today we're joined by Joe
Marini, who's going to be
joining us in our Mountain
View office.
Special thanks to Louis Gray
and to Peter Lubbers for
helping us get this set up.
Normally we broadcast out here
in New York City and have
people join from London, but we
decided to switch things up
a little bit today.
If you're joining us for the
first time, and want to talk
about this, be sure to add the
Chrome Apps hashtag to any of
your comments or any of the
stuff that you want to talk
about online.
Joe is going to be talking with
the Media Galleries API.
The Media Galleries API is
pretty slick in that it lets
you get access to all of the
videos, the pictures, and the
music that's sitting on your
computer, just like you would
be able to do with any
other native app.
We wanted to make sure that
Chrome Apps had this
capability.
So with that, I'll pass it over
to Joe who's going to
start talking about the new
Media Galleries API.
JOE MARINI: All right,
thanks, Pete.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, developers.
Thanks for joining us.
I am Joe Marini.
I'm a developer advocate here
at Google and Chrome Apps is
one of the things I focus on.
As Pete mentioned, I'm going to
be talking about the Media
Galleries API.
If you want to follow along with
us, there's a GitHub repo
I'll show in a moment.
There's also the documentation
available online at
developer.chrome.com/apps.
And in fact, that's the window
I'm showing right now.
So this is the API I will
be talking about.
And as Pete mentioned, the
Media Galleries API is
essentially intended to provide
access to the media
that the user has stored on
their device-- their pictures,
their music, their movies,
and so on.
And this API gives you access
to that via Chrome Apps.
So it's a pretty simple API.
There's really only one function
you have to worry
about, and it's this
one right here.
It's called get media
file systems.
This function takes an object
that describes the kind of
media you're trying to access
and then a callback function
which will be called back with
the file systems representing
the various kinds of media
on the user's system.
So that's the documentation if
you want to read through it.
I prefer to actually
work in live code.
So let's go over to the code and
take a look at how this is
actually written.
Well, actually before
I do that let me--
PETE LEPAGE: Actually,
Joe, can I ask
a real quick question?
JOE MARINI: Sure.
PETE LEPAGE: What's the
difference between using the
Media Galleries API and actually
going and using like
the HTML5 file system to go
access a picture that the user
has on their system?
Why would I use one
or the other?
JOE MARINI: Yeah, that's
a great question.
Actually, they're
complementary.
The callback that I just
mentioned that the media file
systems comes back
with gives you an
HTML5 file system object.
Well, actually, it's an array
of these objects.
Each one of them represents the
different media systems on
the user's computer.
The main difference is that the
media system that you get
back only contains the media
types that the Chrome Apps
platform supports on
the user's device.
So you don't have to worry about
parsing through files
that the system can't play back
or anything like that.
So think of it as a convenience
way of getting at
the locations on the user's
device of where
the media is stored.
The system worries about where
those things are located.
You don't have to go traipsing
through the user's device
using the file system API.
It just makes things
a lot easier.
But the objects that
you get are
actual file system objects.
So it's a nice little
convenience thing.
PETE LEPAGE: And I think the
other important thing to call
out there is that the HTML5
file system API gives you
access to a small sort of
sandbox portion of the user's
hard drive.
It doesn't give you like full
access to the user's hard
drive, right?
JOE MARINI: Unless you
specifically ask for the
user's permission.
If you're OK with throwing up
an open dialogue or a save
dialogue, then fine, you
can go write files to
your heart's content.
But yes, this actually gives you
access to an entire folder
with the user's permission.
So it's a nice convenience
feature.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
JOE MARINI: Yeah.
And in fact, the sample I'm
going to be showing is in our
Google Chrome GitHub repo.
And I'm showing that on
the screen right now.
So if you go to github.com/googl
echrome/chromeappsamples, and
you scroll down to the Media
Gallery folder right here,
that's the code I'm going to
be working in.
So if you want to follow along
with me on your own
machine, feel free.
Quickly, let me show you what
the app looks like.
I'm going to jump over
here to Chrome.
This is the Canary build,
by the way.
And I'm just going to launch
this app right here.
And this is the Media
Gallery Explorer.
This is the sample that's in
that repo that I'm going to be
talking about.
So let me just quickly show
you how it works.
You can see the UI, I've got
three buttons up here.
I've got a couple different
places in the UI that show the
various media information.
So I'm just going to click on
the Get Galleries Info button.
And you can see that right here
in this little div it
says gallery count three--
music, pictures, and movies.
Now it didn't ask me for
permission because I've
already run this app on my
machine before and I
specifically granted this
application permission to go
get those galleries.
If I want to explicitly ask for
permission or for the user
to choose galleries,
I can do that too.
So the Select Galleries button
here brings up the UI that
allows the user to specify
which galleries
I have access to.
So I can go ahead and turn
off movies, for example.
Or if I want to add another
folder, I can click the Add
button and then add other
folders to the default system
folders for Media Galleries.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, cool.
JOE MARINI: Yeah, it's
pretty neat.
So when I click the Grant
Permissions, now you'll see
that that div has changed.
Now I only have access to the
music and pictures folder.
So I'm going to go ahead and
click the Scan Galleries
button now.
And when I click Scan Galleries,
you see on the
left-hand side of the screen
there in this div, I've got
the contents my music and my
pictures folder showing up.
And I'll just click on one
of these pictures.
This is a photo that I took on
the rooftop of the Google San
Francisco offices.
You can see that here's
our roof deck.
And it was a pretty nice day.
And I'm just going to
scroll over, and
there's the Bay Bridge.
So I can go ahead and just
take a look through these
various pictures.
And you can see that the picture
content is being read
in and displayed in the div
there on the right.
I could do the same
thing with music.
If I click on a music file,
you'll see that I get a music
player control in the user
interface there.
So this is the sample that
I'm going to be talking
about in the code.
So let's jump over
to the code.
And I'm using Sublime Text here,
but you can use whatever
code editor you're
happy with it.
So let's start off by
taking a look at the
manifest.json file.
This is the file that determines
what permissions
the application has and so on.
And right here on line seven--
this is the one you need
to pay attention to--
I'm asking for permission to
the Media Galleries API.
And I'm requesting read
access, and I'm also
requesting that the system
auto-detects where the media
galleries are.
So when I call this, the system
will say, well, sure,
I'll tell you where they are to
begin with and if the user
wants to add more, they
can add more.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
So that means, on a PC or on a
Mac, you're always going to
get the right path.
You don't have to worry
about, hey, where
is this file located?
Is it in like /users?
JOE MARINI: Exactly.
You don't have to memorize what
the default paths on the
different platforms are.
It just tells you.
PETE LEPAGE: And if it changes,
you don't have to
deal with it either.
JOE MARINI: Exactly.
If the user decides to change
the locations, again, the
system makes that transparent.
You don't have to worry
about any of that.
So that's the manifest.json
file.
Let's run over to what I call
the runtime.js file.
This is basically the
background page.
This controls the way the
application is launched.
A couple of things
I'm doing here.
First, I'm handling the
onLaunched event right here.
I've got an addListener
for onLaunched.
And what I'm doing is creating
the window, and then inside
that window I'm setting a
global variable called
mgabrestart.
And the reason I'm doing this
is because I was playing
around with the API for when
apps are launched as opposed
to being restarted.
And I wanted to see if I
could just make the app
automatically read the gallery
as if it was restarted versus
being just initially launched.
So over down in the onRestarted
event, I have the
same kind of code where I create
the window, but I set
that variable to true to
indicate that the app was
restarted instead of launched.
That's all this does.
This is typical background
page for a Chrome App.
The HTML files, also pretty
straightforward, just got some
buttons that control the UI.
I've got some divs that
contain the content.
I have the script tag right
here that includes my code
that actually runs the
application, and that's
media-gallery.js.
So let's jump over to that file
because this is where the
meat of the code is.
And I'm going to scroll all the
way down to the bottom.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Joe, if it's
possible, could you bump
up your text?
We've got some people on
YouTube asking you
to bump that up.
JOE MARINI: Oh, sure, yes.
I will be happy to
bump the text up.
Hang on one second.
Let's go ahead and make
the font size.
There we go out.
That should be easier to read.
Hopefully, that's better.
I got a nice full screen
of code there.
All right, so here in my
window.addEventListener for
the loading event, I'm
setting up the UI.
I've got some addEventListener
calls on the various buttons.
And then down here, I'm
listening for the change event
on that select [INAUDIBLE]
that's on the left-hand
side there.
So whenever the [INAUDIBLE]
changes in the media gallery
content of the list, I have an
event that fires, and then
I update the selection.
And this is where I read the
picture, read the audio,
whatever it is.
So let's actually take a
look at how this works.
Right up here on line
240, this is
where the magic happens.
You can see right here that if
the app was restarted, I call
the getMediaFileSystems API.
This is the restart case.
For the launched case, I
actually wait for the Scan
Galleries button
to be clicked.
But it does the same thing, it
calls getMediaFileSystems.
And it takes that little options
object right there.
The property I'm passing in
is called interactive.
And it says if_needed.
Now I can pass in if_needed,
which means if the user hasn't
already granted permission,
it will be prompted to
the user to do so.
However, if the user has already
granted permissions,
that dialog doesn't show up.
I could also pass in
yes, which will
always show the dialog.
Or I can pass in no, which means
don't show the dialog if
you don't have to.
So the getMediaFileSystems
API call takes
that options object.
And here is the callback
function.
It's called getGalleriesInfo.
So let's go ahead and
scroll up to the
getGalleriesInfo function.
That's right here.
The first thing I'm going
to do is clear out
that content div.
That's the div on the right-hand
side that shows the
pictures, the music,
and so on.
And then, when this function
is called, this parameter
right here, the results
parameter, that's going to be
an array of HTML5 file system
objects representing the
various media galleries.
So the folder for pictures,
the folder for
music, and so on.
PETE LEPAGE: So logically, you
should get three back, and
then I would just [? zoom ?]
within each of the folders.
Oh, cool
JOE MARINI: Yeah, three, two,
however many you requested,
however many the user
granted access to.
So I'm checking here to see if
the length of that results
array is greater than zero,
because then I've
got stuff to process.
And then I'm just using this
forEach loop right here with
this callback function to go
over each one of the gallery
pieces of information
that comes back.
Now the gallery information
comes back as a JSON string.
And it gives you an ID
for the gallery and
it gives you a name.
The name is a human-readable
string like music, or
pictures, or whatever it is
localized to your system.
The ID is a tag that you can use
to uniquely identify the
media gallery that you're
working with.
So you can save that aside and
use it to go back and get
files at a later date
or whatever.
So that's what I'm using
that there for.
So I loop over each one of these
IDs so that I know how
many galleries I'm
dealing with.
And I store those in this global
variable right here
that holds all the different
pieces of arrays.
And then that's how I get the
information about what
galleries are on the system.
Now the Scan Galleries button
fires off of this function
right here called
scanGalleries.
And again, it takes
an argument for a
particular file system.
So what's going to happen is
it's going to loop over each
one of those array elements
for however many
galleries I got back.
And each time it's going to do
that, it's going to call this
addGallery function.
So I parse in the name
object for the
particular file system.
Again, that's an ID and
a human-readable name.
And then I'm going to call
this addGallery function,
which goes through each gallery
and enumerates all the
different file objects
that are in there.
And so what I do is I create
a new object called a
GalleryData.
And you can see that
in my code later.
That's just a little JavaScript
object I have to
keep track of the various file
names, and sizes of files, and
different things the
app needs to do.
And then I call the createReader
function.
Now this is a part of the
HTML5 file system API.
Remember, earlier, I said that
they're complimentary.
So you get a file system object
and then you use the
file system APIs on that
gallery object
to do the file reading.
So I create the reader.
And then on the reader I
call the readEntries.
Again, more HTML5 file system
standard stuff.
I have a function here
called scanGallery.
That's the callback that's going
to get called by the
file system to read
the actual folder.
And that's up here, so
I'll scroll up to
the scanGallery function.
So the scanGallery function is
going to get a whole bunch of
file system entries.
These are the individual file
entries for each particular
file inside that gallery.
So I'm going see if the length
of the entries array is zero.
And when that happens, the
file system API is done
calling this callback.
It's processed all
the elements in
that particular folder.
And the reason that I need to do
this is because the way the
file system works, especially
in the async version, this
function is going to get called
over and over again,
because it may not get called
with all of the entries in a
particular folder the
very first time.
The system is just going to
keep calling this function
until there's no more
files and no more
folders left to process.
So if it's not equal to
zero, that means I've
got stuff to do.
So I'm going to have this loop
here going from zero to the
number of entries
in the array.
I check to see if the
entry is a file.
And if it is a file, I have a
function here called addItem
that's going to add the item to
that little select list on
the left-hand side there.
And then I've got this little
closer function right here
that's going to get
the metadata for
that particular file.
In this case, all I'm
interested in
is the size in bytes.
And I'm not really doing
anything with it.
I'm just showing that
it's possible to get
information like this.
If it's a directory, on the
other hand, and not a file,
I'm going to push that directory
onto a stack that
I'm using to process
subfolders.
And then down here at the
bottom, I'm just going to call
readEntries again.
And so this function is going
to keep calling itself over
and over until there's
no more files.
Now at the end of this function,
that select list in
the div on the left is going
to be full of all the files
that I've processed
and read in.
So now let's go take a look at
the function for the change
handler and see what happens
when the user actually makes a
selection in the list.
So if I scroll back down here
to the bottom, remember
there's this function here
called updateSelection.
So let's scroll on over to
the updateSelection code.
And that is right up here.
PETE LEPAGE: Joe, one thing I
noticed in this particular
example, you didn't use
an MVC framework or
anything like that.
Is there a reason why in this
sample you didn't do that?
JOE MARINI: Just
hacking around.
So I wanted to make a sample
where the code for the Media
Galleries API was the focus.
And everybody's got their
personal preferences.
People bond with their
MVC frameworks.
PETE LEPAGE: It's true,
Angular rocks.
JOE MARINI: Absolutely, so
please go use Angular.
But whatever MVC framework you
feel like using, that's fine.
I just didn't want that to
be getting in the way.
So here in the updateSelection
code, I'm going over the
length of the gallery array
to get the system that the
selected file belongs to.
Remember, I stored aside the ID,
and now I'm going to take
that file and figure out which
gallery it's a part of.
It might be in music, it
might be in pictures,
it might be in movies.
And what I'm going to do is,
based on the kind of file that
it is, whether it's a picture,
or music, or whatever, I'm
going to add that content
to the div.
The way that I'm doing that is
up here I've got these arrays
with the various
file suffixes.
So I've got image formats like
PNG, and BMP and JPEGs.
For video, I've got MOV, and
MPEG, and WEBM and so on.
So that way, I could figure
out what kind of file is.
So back down here, let's go back
down to the code where I
handle the selection.
I'm using these HTML5
data attributes.
Each time an item is added to
the select list, I store the
path to the item as
a data attribute.
So that way I can just
easily get it again.
So that way, when I get the full
path to the item, again,
using the HTML5 file
system API right
here to get the file.
And when that function callback
gets called, I have a
file entry.
And all I do is clear out the
content div to clear out
whatever was in there before.
And then I have these various
functions, addImage, addAudio,
addVideo, and so on.
Let's just take a look at the
addImage case because the rest
of them are just pretty
much carbon copies.
So for adding a picture item,
this function right here,
addImageToContentDiv,
all it does is it
creates an image element.
It appends the image element
into the content div, and then
returns that image element back
to the calling function,
so back down here.
And assuming the new element was
created, I have a function
here that uses the HTML5
file system to just
read the raw bytes.
So I created a new File
Reader object.
I set up onerror handler.
I set up an onloadend handler
function right here.
So when the data is finished
reading, I simply set the
source of the image element
to the result of
the file read operation.
So this is going to come
back as a data URL.
Right here on the next line,
on 130, I'm calling
reader.readAsDataURL.
So if it's an image, it will get
read in as an image data
URL versus music, versus
video, and so on.
And then I just simply append
that content into the source
attribute for, say, the image,
or the movie, or the video.
So that's basically all
there is to it.
I'm using the HTML5 file system
to read the raw bytes.
And I'm just relying on the
Media Gallery API to give me
access to the HTML5 file systems
that represent the
media galleries.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
JOE MARINI: Pretty
straightforward, yeah.
Code is online.
This sample is in
our GitHub repo.
I encourage you to fork it, and
play with it, test it out.
And that's pretty much
all there is to it.
So if there's questions, we
can start taking those.
PETE LEPAGE: Just one question
that I wanted to
shoot off the bat.
Is it read-write or is it just
read-only right now?
JOE MARINI: So that's
a good question.
So the intention is when the API
is complete, you'll have
access to read-only, read-write,
and you'll also be
able to add new file content to
the user's media galleries.
So as the API stands today, we
only support read-only access.
So write is coming, add files
is coming, they're
just not there yet.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, and I noticed
as I was looking through the
documentation preparing for this
that some of these things
are still under the experimental
and some are no
longer under experimental.
Do you want to talk to talk
just really quickly about
what's still under experimental,
what's not?
JOE MARINI: If I remember
correctly, the actual code for
getting the media galleries,
let me bring
up that page again.
The Media Galleries API itself
was recently moved out from
experimental.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, so that's
what it looked like.
JOE MARINI: Yeah.
So you no longer need to put
the experimental keyword in
front of it.
It's ready to go.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, awesome.
Let me bring up some of
the questions that
we've got over here.
So [? DJazz ?]
from Sweden wants to know if he
can access the local file
system using standard open, and
save, save as dialogs with
a permissions flag.
And I think this is
not necessarily
specifically with--
JOE MARINI: Yeah, this is not
a Media Galleries specific
question, but the
answer is yes.
If you're using the HTML5 file
system, you are able to invoke
an open or save dialog.
In fact, outside of the local
application sandbox, that's
the only way to get file
content onto the
user system, so yes.
But the answer is
yes, you can.
That was a rather long-winded
way of saying, yes.
PETE LEPAGE: Excellent.
And then the second question
that we had, let me just
reread it here.
Sorry.
Web Intents, I'm going to
skip that question and
go to the next one.
JOE MARINI: Oh, I think the
web's intents are good.
PETE LEPAGE: Ba boom chang.
Paul, that one was for you.
All right.
And actually, it looks like
that's all the questions that
we have today.
So nice easy session.
I want to thank everybody
for joining us.
We'll be back next week.
Renato and I are going
to be joining you.
So Renato's going
to be joining, I
guess, me from Sao Paulo.
And we're going to be talking,
I believe, about the Web View
API, so being able to actually
embed, effectively, a web view
within your Chrome
Application.
So that's going to give you a
lot more flexibility to be
able to do some things that you
weren't really easily able
to do before or to be able to
add stuff to your page.
With that, I want to thank
everybody for joining
us again this week.
It was a really great session.
Thanks to Joe.
Thanks to Peter and Louis in
Mountain View for helping make
this happen.
With that, we'll see
you guys next week.
Thanks very much.
JOE MARINI: Thanks, everybody.
Hit me up on G+.
I'm Joe Marini on G+.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Thanks, Joe.